I think it's surprising and really
pleasing to think about things that you
do know
but you haven't turned them over in your
mind it's almost like a rock that when
you flip it over you see all kinds of
bugs and dirt and the whole thing is
just moving and etc it's the same rock
you've just flipped it over so here's an
example so an oak tree you know maybe
you've had an oak tree in your life or
your yard or whatever so I do the
experiment where I say what if every
single ACORN
that oak tree ever produced turned into
another tree what if every acorn that
was ever produced by every tree turned
into another tree well animals would
never have evolved I mean the earth
would be so packed we'd be so up to our
eyebrows and trees you know nothing else
could move and that allows me to step
into the very interesting story of how
plants approach reproduction so
differently than we do they put out
mind-boggling numbers of offspring and
then those offspring have very very low
odds of success they have very low odds
of germinating and other the ones that
even start to grow a vast vast subset
will actually rut and of those a vast
subset will grow to any kind of height
and then of that another tree right so
if an oak tree produces acorns for a
hundred years in a row all it needs is
one of those acorns to become the
replacement tree to still have an oak
inhabiting that chunk of the planet
right so the seed and you've seen
hundreds of thousands of seeds just in
one month probably you you know let
alone in the food you eat you come
across seeds all the time but each one
of those seeds is an impossible thing
it's it's a piece of hope that's
produced with almost no chance of
success and then you can flip that over
and say every tree that you see was once
a hopeless seed like that and so the
trees in front of us are this impossible
thing it's it's this impossible journey
that almost never happens
and yet it results in something that's
the biggest oldest longest living life
form on the terrestrial surface and so I
think the real joy for me is that I can
take things that are already familiar to
you and by sharing the story of how I've
learned to look at them you can see
those things you've been seeing a little
differently with a little more joy and a
little more connection and that's what I
really like to do so I talk about
curiosity driven research as questions
that we try to answer why is that tree
growing successfully in that place but
never in that place that's a curiosity
question it's the kind of question a
little kid could come up with why don't
we have those trees at our house now
buried in the answer might be something
that could give us better fruit someday
that we can sell in the marketplace and
feed hungry people with but that result
that application to growing food for
people is buried several steps below
that answer my part of that is to look
at that first answer what is that tree
what does it do why is it there and we
call that the curiosity driven piece
because that answer will be basically
turned over to other experts who know
how that might play out into something
that is important for the marketplace
but there's no substitute for that first
step for that little kid question and
all the work that goes you've got to get
a bus ticket and
go to that place you got to go to that
place you've got to count them you've
got to bring some of the tissues back
there's an expense associated with that
particular type of work and I talk very
much in my book about where that funding
is coming from and how it's diminishing
rapidly and how it's not nearly enough
to support all the curiosity that the
public has and all the science that
we've trained a generation to do
[Music]